i kind of think that contributed to the
whole lunar love good vibe because she
is a bit spacey if you were cast in
harry potter as a preteen odds are you
got to use your own voice it's leviosa
not livio
but the adult cast got to play all of
the creepy villain characters and weird
comedic types we're taking a look at the
actors who really put a lot of work into
their characters and didn't really sound
like themselves by the end
you'd like to cover up and um
and i said you're completely right i'm
afraid voldemort isn't you darling rafe
finds took inspiration from his nephew
who played a young voldemort and no we
aren't talking about christian coulson
who played tom riddle in chamber of
secrets we're talking half-blood prince
tom played by hero finds he has such a
wonderful quality of a a boy's
loneliness because the world has
rejected him that snake-like whisper
finds brings to the character obviously
isn't how he talks normally
you're a full harry potter
and you will lose if he actually spoke
like that he probably never would have
gotten very far as an actor as it's an
intimidating enough persona to scare the
gryffindor out of daniel radcliffe but
the voice evolves throughout the series
when voldemort first receives his body
and goblet of fire he sounds like a sick
and elderly man
13 years it's been but as the character
grows stronger so does his voice
severus
i was beginning to worry you had lost
your way
and you would know voldy is just one
character rafe finds can play if you'd
ever seen grand budapest hotel which you
totally should
how's that supposed to make me feel wait
what in the baboo frick she played
myrtle in her 30s
you heard that right myrtle was played
by established voice actor shirley
henderson who has since played the
little baboo in the rise of skywalker
which do you think de-aged her more the
translucent ghost thing or the bangs
because bangs were definitely the
de-aging tech of the time
maybe it was the fact she was five foot
nothing or maybe it was just the squeaky
voice
and it fell through the top of my head
and here's the real her when you can't
see right through her a bit of both i
mean it's exciting but it's also a bit
uncomfortable at the same time if we
could play any role in the franchise it
would definitely be bellatrix
helena bonham carter definitely had the
most memorable role in the series a lot
of bellatrix's character came from
helena's strong relationship with the
director who allowed her to play and
explore on set who knows how to play
itsy bitsy
baby and the rest of the tone of voice
came from the fake teeth she used which
by the way she was the one who asked for
the teeth in the first place and also
kept them after filming wrapped well
she's just like this mad child which is
why she doesn't brush her teeth but
there you have it helena is much more
laid back than bellatrix in real life
everybody seems to make us more
interesting than we actually are we are
living for jason isaac's catty voice
theft the inspiration jason had for
lucius malfoy's voice came from two
different places it came from a teacher
at his drama school that teacher didn't
give him any good acting tips no
actually the two quite disliked each
other so jason just stole his voice and
then he combined it with that of a
famous art critic using a fabricated
upper-class british accent that is my
true mask
no one was confident that this voice
would win over audiences but jason was
and it paid off listen to how quickly he
can just jump into character i turned to
daniel and i said let's hope mr bottom
will always be around to save the day
why so serious sorry that pun was too
easy given how down to earth sirius
black really is later on in the series
it's jarring to watch his performance
when he was fresh out of azkaban i can't
explain any of that it's just the way it
it's worked out amazing to think that
man created this character why don't you
run along and play with your chemistry
set for gary oldman he approaches his
characters from one of two places it's
normally a vocal thing or
or a physical thing
rather than just letting it be purely
intellectual
it's been years since your last
nightmare about dolores umbridge two
years before her casting a friend of
imeldas read harry potter and then said
she'd be perfect for the part she read
it and thought small squat ugly toad
like woman thanks a lot we wouldn't
describe her voice as toad like more
like cookies scratching against a
chalkboard and not like good cookies but
like raisin cookies in case you don't
remember it and need more nightmare fuel
here's your reminder there is nothing
out there dear who do you imagine was to
attack children like yourself well
imelda staunton speaks just an octave or
so lower it's not really legal
but it's necessary i think that sums her
up it's also important to see her out of
costume
you know they took oh are you and i go
step away step away raise your hand if
you didn't realize emma thompson played
sybil trelawny between the hair the
glasses the costume the behavior and of
course the voice we understand if you
didn't recognize her together we shall
cast ourselves into the future
bet you would love to cast yourself into
the past to relay this information to a
younger you huh i'm not really in it
enough to impress them
okay good then we're off the hook we
didn't know it was her if you play this
video at 1.25 speed luna will sound like
ivana there's nothing exceptionally
ordinary about ivana lynch she still has
that whimsical quality when she speaks
the biggest difference really has to be
the pace yvonne is spending just a
little less time in the clouds or
looking at thestrals than luna i wish i
felt this relaxed when i when i was
younger actually wait more relaxed than
you were playing luna did we hear that
right
no but i've done several toes and
how different are they really maybe in
the world of harry potter noses and toes
are not so different but in the doctor's
office we bet they're very different now
for our favorite grumbly caretaker filch
was a fun one for david bradley he
didn't talk much but he was a huge part
of the series always there
always watching always grumbling and
groaning but still finding small moments
of happiness when harry would find
himself in a pickle oh dear we are in
trouble
the secret to getting the voice of the
character is the false teeth all i've
got to do is just pop these in there
and it's an instant filch timothy played
a character that couldn't be farther
from himself there's something jarring
about comparing timothy spall and his
character peter pettigrew because he
really gives off politician vibes i
think are we gonna see the birth of a
religion are we harry potter
actually we meant that pettigrew gave
off the vibes
have no idea the weapon she possesses
yeah that's better in all seriousness
timothy put a lot of work into the role
and a lot of his inspiration came from
pettigrew's 12 years of living as
scabbers the rat
the wizarding world of harry potter
truly lends itself to some magical voice
acting choices
in these lessons i will attempt to
penetrate to your mind from false teeth
to art critics it just goes to show
inspiration can come from anywhere one
of turner's things on the wall and i
look at it and i think the hell did i do
that i can't even remember doing it
which actor's vocal transformation
impressed you the most leave your
thoughts in the comments and thanks for
joining us at the things